so wie zäher jeder mensch heutzutage
habe auch ich instagram also folgt mir
da auf instagram ist es möglich dass man
sich untereinander nachrichten schreibt
und diese werden im fachjargon die apps
genannt ich habe 100 heutige video idee
überlegt dass ich euch einfach einige
instagram die ms zeige die mir so
zugesendet werden ja damit fangen wir
jetzt an
nachdem ich dich einmal in bielefeld in
der stadt gesehen habe bekomme ich dich
einfach nicht mehr aus meinem kopf
heraus es ist nicht dieses teenager
gelaber sondern dass ich einfach die ich
gesehen habe und auch wusste wer du bist
aber nicht so durchgedreht bin als ich
dich sah weil ich ein fan bin sondern
weil du einfach ein super mensch bist
bis zu dem punkt dachte ich mir okay ist
jetzt vielleicht irgendwie einfach eine
person die mich mag oder so aber da es
keine großen sorgen oder was mache ich
hier eigentlich auf jeden fall hat sie
allerdings direkt danach noch
geschrieben und jede nacht die ich in
meinem klatschenden bett verbringen
träume ich auch von dir ja da
das war schon ein bisschen komisch ich
das ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig
verstehen also okay die person ihr habt
mich jetzt auch schon mal getroffen in
bielefeld soll ja vorkommen wenn ich
hier wohne aber ich kann das ehrlich
gesagt überhaupt nicht verstehen dass
leute irgendwie sich direkt so also ich
meine du kennst mich ja nicht also wie
warum also herr hallo contractor ich
wollte dich fragen ob du mich in deinem
nächsten video grüßen kannst oder mich
in deinem nächsten bild verlinkt oder
meine bilder oder mich vielleicht auch
volks bitte einfach einfach nein das ist
etwas was mir so häufig gesendet wird
und zwar luca kannst du nicht mal mein
profil angucken kann es nicht mal ein
paar bilder von mir leid nicht zu mir
nicht recht folgen glaubt befreundet bin
ich eher leute folgen möchte dann folge
ich diesen leuten und wenn ich finde
dass bildern eis sind dann lag ich diese
bilder aber nicht fallen mir leute sagen
dass ich das tun sollte
na ja auch so gab mal ein obwohl das
nicht ganz sicher ist das nicht
bei der nächsten em hat mir eine person
gestern um 0.13 geschrieben hey luca und
dein herz und danach hat sie mir heute
um 00 22 geschrieben kannst du mir bitte
antworten also das soll überhaupt nicht
angeberisch jetzt fliegen oder so habe
ich bekomme 500 bis 1000 instagram die
ms pro tag und ich schaue dann nicht
täglich rein und meistens auch nicht
wöchentlich also es tut mir leid er sie
nicht geantwortet habe allerdings bin
ich auch wenn man jemand anschreiben mit
hey so ein bisschen ist ein bisschen und
unkreativ hallo darf ich mit ukulele
reden w fragezeichen ich möchte ihn
etwas fragen
du möchtest mit einer ukulele reden weg
und was möchtest du im fragen beim
fantreffen wird mir unglaublich häufig
gesagt er luca richte mal bitte um die
schöne grüße von mir aus und ich denke
mir dann nachher wirklich immer wenn ich
zu hause bin gibt es beim büro
toxikologie an und denken wir nur sehr
schöne grüße von martin von martina von
von martin und martina von luca wir
haben die 95.000 leicht geschafft du
musst noch ein neues horror wie du hier
machen wie wäre es mit dem spiels
bookies gianluca wir haben die 95.000
likes geschafft muss aber ein neues
video machen luca wir haben die 50.000
lies geschafft sein
machen wir haben die vermutlich habe ja
ich hatte bis vor kurzem eine serie auf
meinem kanal wo ich drei vier fünf teile
von hochladen habe und zwar habe ich
immer gesagt wenn diese zahl erreicht
wie dann lade ich ein horror game hoch
das ist dementsprechend sehr spannend da
ich horror spiele über alles hasse und
die ja weil ich so spiele so sehr hasste
habe ich seitdem noch keinen neuen
partner von hochgeladen geile bilder
kannst du mir folgen einlud wollen die
chinesen
märz mich ja doch nicht ich weiß nicht
genau was ich da jetzt bemerken soll
außer das lesen da waren drei
rechtschreibfehler in drei wörtern
homepages montalcino fernseher via so
vieler in germany das keyboard buddy
bears ratings von nadja ich habe
tatsächlich einen fan in serbien ihr
müsst euch das mal vorstellen so ich
mache deutsche videos und da sitzt ein
mädchen namens nadja in serbien und
guckt sich meine deutschen videos an
nadja wenn du das siehst du bist eher
ihren frau wie viel wird der mehrfarbige
rudi der am ersten zwölfter in deinen
job kommen kosten das ist sehr gut dass
du mir das geschrieben hast und zwar
weil da und hier seht ihr oben schon
werbe video eingeblendet ganz einfach
weil ich gerade wenn ein shop rede und
zwar sind dass hier die preise für die
produkte die am 11 12
luca schock kommen werden ich weiß dass
einige wahrscheinlich wieder ankommen
werden und sagen werden
das ist jetzt aber zwei euro teurer als
hier in youtuber shop xy kräuter wir
produzieren die sachen italien achten
dass sie auf qualität der rudi ist multi
core wieder sind vier verschiedene
stoffe zusammen gesteckt worden das
lupus shirt ist don walsh das heißt
jedes shirt was in den shop kommen wird
ist ein unikat und sieht von der
waschung her anders aus ich glaube ich
hätte mich mittlerweile ich möchte
lieber wenige produkte ein oder zweimal
im jahr herausbringen
als irgendwie alle zwei wochen irgendwas
neues und dann immer nur so das gleiche
aber mit dem anderen trend also ich
versuche jedes mal ein bisschen was
neues zu machen was qualitativ hat auch
geil ist aber ich möchte niemanden
zwingen sich etwas zu kaufen
ich würde es natürlich sehr freuen ihr
bekommt auch wieder sticker dazu wir
haben diesmal sogar neiße hologramm
sticker aber dass er die tage bei mir
auf snapshot und instagram wollen jetzt
auch die letzte sache ganz kurz zum shop
und zwar machen ist ja immer so dass 48
stunden vor dem launch am ersten 12 die
website down genommen wird so dass wir
die neuen änderungen am shop design und
so vornehmen können und zwar wird das
diesmal der 29 hälfte sein also zwei
tage vorher und bis zum 29 11 10 also ab
heute dem 17 uhr werden wir bis zum 29
elf noch zwölf tage lang bekommt ihr auf
diese fünf produkte 20 prozent rabatt
mit dem kot luca 20 der diese produkte
werden ab dem ersten zwölfter nicht mehr
produziert und nicht mehr im shop
verfügbar sein also falls die bock aufs
shirt noch habt oder auf die bettwäsche
oder auf das weiße shirt oder sowie
werden ab dem ersten zwölften komplett
aus dem sortiment genommen
deswegen kaufte die dann am besten
vorher mit dem computer 20 prozent und
jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten dienstag
an die m days herz dann einen tag später
bitte antworten damit ich sehe dass es
gesehen dann elf tage später hast dann
noch mal zwei wochen später herz ja was
was soll ich da antworten dass ich dass
ich was gesehen habe bei der nächsten
instagram nachrichten einfach ein bild
geschickt auf dem ich ein panda bin okay
habe ich tatsächlich besser aus als ich
jetzt gerade einen klar ich bin ein
riesen fan von die dir tut mir leid
wegen den rechtschreibfehlern klasse
weißt du da willst du dich schon
berichtigen oder machst du dann auch
noch falsch stadt gibt von mir auf jeden
fall in der woche
luca luka ja was willst du den nächsten
instagram die m mächtig ganz kurz etwas
zu sagen und zwar wurde in einer story
erwähnt mit dem untertitel ich liebe
dich ed lay san luca ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich finde es schön werden mir
leute schreiben dass sie irgendwie
mitfeiern oder meinen content feiern
oder meine bilder feiern oder meine art
oder keine ahnung wenn aussehen soll ja
auch vollkommen bei wenigen menschen
aber ich bin ganz ehrlich diese worte
ich liebe dich hier sind sehr große
worte bitte bei legt euch ob ihr diese
worte einer person sagen wollte ihr nur
aus dem internet kennt sony mich oder
jemand anderem
also natürlich kann man die wörter öfter
sagen also ich liebe dich aber ich
glaube ihr wisst was ich meine ich fühle
mich dann mal so ein bisschen unwohl
wenn wir leute sagen ich liebe dich und
ich hey na los und man neigt luca du
bist ja ja das stimmt schwitzen kühe
unter schwarzen flecken mehr als unter
weißem ist es dann verdammter ernst da
fasst sie vom video meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen like da ich bin morgen
auf der style o rama in dortmund also
wenn ihr auch da sehen wir uns als ihr
wollt dass ich öfter mal auf instagram
die ems reagiere ich hatte ja frühe
serie dass ich auf instagram kommentar
unter meinen bildern reagiert habe
dann schreibt man in die kommentare
instagram und folgen auf instagram ich
heißt nämlich laser luca und ich bin
kurz vor zwei millionen abonnenten
das was ihr vom video das was jetzt hier
vom video hier können jetzt jemanden
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job ausschenken hier findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auch die glocken
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]